Fortnite livestream draws in more than 1 million viewers
Drake sets record with his Fortnite Twitch debut
Fortnite holds the record for the most videos related to a video game uploaded in a single month EVER!!!
200,000 VIEWERS VS 20,000.
They're getting paid?
They're getting paid to play Fortnite?
They are getting paid for it!
YouTube Gaming,
it's all Fortnite!
(Deep satanic voice)
It's all Fortnite!
(Even more satanic voice!)
It's all Fortniiiiiiiite!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA!!!!!!!!!
(Reverses to normal Pewds)
Hey, how's it going guys? It's me.
I am here,
Pewdiep...
It's Pewdiepie
I am here to talk about my favorite video game of all time.
Fortnite.
(Clearly Fortnite)
I love this game.
So fun.
You know hat I look for in a game?
No, no, no, go away
That's right. I prefer th-
the rip-off of the game.
That's my favourite versio- *laughs*
Oh, sorry!
I meant the rip-off of the rip-off of the rip-off of the rip-off of the rip-off of the rip-off of a game.
Now that's what I call original content!
Fortnite is just everywhere lately.
And uh, I think I'm the only one.
I'm the only one left that hasn't played it.
So today I thought we are going to play it.
(No please...)
Oh wow, look.
It looks like we are gonna win it!
Just gotta keep building, which is what this game is all about, apparently
*many bangs*
*burps*
Where is the other guy?
Oh there he is!
Uh jeez, I don't know if I can do this...
*epic gun fight sounds*
Oh I did it, yeah! (Nope)
Yeah I did it! (No you didn't)
(oh look at how cheerful he is, this is totally not sarcastic)
*cuts to YouTube video*
Oh sorry I didn't realize I had to,
play the game.
Wait, I have to play the game myself and not just,
react to prerecorded footage that someone else did?
Instead we are going to react to some
Fortnite cringe, everybody.
*chuckles*
that's right
I am better than everyone else so, uh!
I get to do this.
I am just joking of course,
I'm not gonna play Fortnite.
What, do you think I'm some pathetic beta male?
That's right.
We're instead going to laugh at people playing Fortnite.
Starting off with my favorite
Fortinite channel
"Ali-A"
This is capitalism
at it's finest.
Look at this *chuckles*
My god
It's all Fortnite
*chuckles*
Isn't it...
It's a lot of arrows, and there's a lot of Fortnite
And you, you got to appreciate it
Jesus Christ, dude
I especially like this one,
You know, here's a "regular" video
With an interesting concept
200,000 views
Right next to it, "The WORST Fortnite: Battle Royale player EVER! (FUNNY)"
5,000,000 views
I think the main thing I learned about this is- is- is the color.
There's a lot of shiny color here
Cause' I feel like if I took one of my,
regular thumbnails, this is garbage
It needs way more hue on it
Uh, let's see here.
There you g- there you go, that looks much better
I think this is how I will do all my thumbnails from now on
We got to get the kids to watch it, that's how you do it
You just, increase that hue/saturation slider
And you got the kids watching
What's the number two thing?
That's right
The intros, you got to bait the kids in alright,
they're not just going to watch some ten minute video,
unless you have some bait going on
So you got to have something
r/mildlyinteresting
happening, and the just roll the intro
"YOOOOO LOOK AT THAT"
Three, two, one, DROP IT
*Interesting music choice"
Yooooo
Look at that
*EARRAPE*
If you want to find out what's over there,
watch the whole ten minute video guys
It's pretty epic
*EARRAPE*
This rule applies to all YouTubers
But I think, I think "Ali-A" does it the finest
"THESE GUYS ARE TRYING TO STEAL MY SECRET LOOT SPOT"
"I do not think so guys"
*more interesting music*
What's he going to do?
*dances some more*
heh
Guess i'll have to watch thirty-four minutes to find out!
This isn't applied to just Ali-A
This formula literally applies to every single Fortnite streamer/YouTuber ever
"A whole inventory of legendaries!"
"Okay, okay now we just need to win the game guys"
Oh my God
What was he doing?
Alright we're down to the top ten
*shots firing*
Oh my god
How did I kill him?
*Whew* seven people alive
*peaceful music plays*
Brad and Sive
Why don't I have a cool flashy intro like all the other cool yo- Fortnite YouTuber's?
* I n h a l e *
Ho-Make one please now
Otherwise
I'm gonna be super angry
Where is the other guy? Oh there he is
Ah geez I don't know if I can do this
* epic intro plays*
*wheeze*
Dat was epic
WOW, what a cool intro
Ali-A has the best intros though
"This is the most crazy base I've ever seen mate"
"This is actually...
...insane"
*Hyuck*
Haha
*gasp*
*cough*
*gasp again*
"OH MY GOD A THIRD ONE"
"FOUR IN ONE GAME!"
"I HAVE NEVER EXPERIENCED THAT IN MY LIFE!"
NO ONE HAS EVER DONE THAT
It's like, uh
We're n- we're not just clickbaiting the clickbait
we gotta clickbait the actual content by now
It's really...
eehhhhh *chuckle*
How far is this gonna go?
A- at the end of the day theyrebfsi...
there will just be no content whatsoever
Just clickbait outta clickbait
Like, "Just keep watching guys"
Well actually, this kinda reminds me of TV cuz, isn't that what they do?
With the, uh. Oh!
"Stay tuned after the commercial!"
"We have some important announcements!"
--And then you watch through the commercial...
There's never something important...
*oh my god...*
I just discovered that TV is a lie!
*smart pewds* oh i'm so woke!
Well we're heading there, we're heading there that's for sure.
If anything i should just start clickbaiting my mid-rolls!
So that, uh..... *chuckle*
You guys will keep watching through the midroll
GUYS SORRY WE GOTTA TAKE A COMMERCIAL MIDROLL HERE
But after this video--uhhhh... the
*COMMERCIAL*
--"THERE'S SOMETHING THERE!!!!"
there is SOMETHING THERE
"It's easy for children to draw with MAGIDRAW™!"
[  KEMONO Drawing by Tsukune Daiga (@Diga_foxdog)  ]
"They draw in a body putting in a positioning points,"
"... and build up the picture!"
"MAGIDRAW™ and JUNIOR MAGIDRAW™"
"The exciting way to draw"
(It's time to release the beast)
"oh hell naw"
WHAAAT THE [funk]
I'M FEELIN ELECTRIFIEEEED ♪
WHAAAT THE--
(ruh roh)
THAT'S A SWEAR!!!!
THAT'S A SWEAR IN THE INTRO
What the frick, man?
I've been trying to censor my swears...
For the FRICKIN longest time...
and he just gets awa-
This bes- better not-- this best not be monetised
or i'm going to get so angry...
R E E E E E E
This is outrageous. I'm tired of this.
I'm tired of YouTube's hypocrisy.
This is favourism
*sneers*
...stupid.
Alright, let's see the dance then.
Let's see the dance
...doin' the fortnite dances.
啊 HEELL YEEAAAA
oAo HEEECK YEEEE
No, no, no
I need more come on
come on
Dance for daddy ;3
9 million views, everybody. 9 million views.
I am not salty by the way
If you think i'm criticising these Fortnite youtubers
because i am jealous
that they're getting millions of views
then you are MISTAKEN.
I am not s...s-so low...
m'kay? (sure....)
I get a lot of views too and they're ALL monetized...
trust me
I got a TON of ads rollin on my videos (of course...)